* Sanfte asiatische Klänge *
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
(Tokio. Was für eine Stadt.)
(Gerade noch sass ich im Flugzeug und
nun: Menschen, Menschen, Menschen.)
(Ich bin Patrick Rohr.)
(Bis vor ein paar Jahren
war ich Fernsehmoderator.)
(Heute bin ich als Fotojournalist
auf der ganzen Welt unterwegs.)
(In Japan möchte ich
ein Buch mit Bildern und Texten
über dieses Land machen.)
(Ich will wissen, wie
die Menschen leben, was sie denken.)
(Ich bin froh,
reist Dennis Ginsig mit mir.)
(Dennis ist Halbjapaner:
Der Vater ist Schweizer,
die Mutter kommt aus Japan.)
(Aufgewachsen
ist Dennis in der Schweiz.)
(Er spricht aber auch Japanisch
und lebte eine Zeit lang in Japan.)
(Darum ist er für mich
nicht nur Sprach-,
sondern auch Kulturübersetzer.)
(In Japan blickt man
nicht einfach so dahinter.)
(Bis man nur schon die vielen
Verhaltensregeln begreift.)
(Beim Essen zu schlürfen
ist für uns z.B. unanständig.)
* Schlürfen *
(In Japan ist das normal.)
(Nur so entfalte sich der
volle Geschmack des Essens im Mund,
erklärt mir Dennis.)
(Ich kann mir vorstellen,
dass diese Reise sehr spannend wird.)
(Ich freue mich auf das Abenteuer.)
* Sanfte japanische Musik *
(Man sagt, Japan sei eine Insel.)
(Das stimmt nicht ganz:
Japan besteht aus über 6'800 Inseln.)
(Sie liegen im Pazifischen Ozean.)
(Die nächsten Nachbarn sind Russland,
China, Nordkorea,
Südkorea und Taiwan.)
(Meine Reise beginnt in Tokio,
der Hauptstadt Japans.)
(10 Mio. Menschen leben hier,
42 Mio. sind es im Grossraum Tokio.)
(Dennis hat mir empfohlen,
fernzusehen.)
(Das japanische Fernsehen
sei sehr lustig.)
Zu-gu-zugucken. Zu-gu-zugucken.
(Sehr lustig und zu meiner Über-
raschung auch sehr schweizerisch.)
Schau mal, diese Muskeln!
* Japanisch *
(Tatsächlich ist die junge Frau
im Heidi-Kostüm halb Schweizerin,
halb Japanerin.
Ihr Name: Christine Haruka Sato.)
* Sie sprechen japanisch. *
(Als Haruka Christine
ist sie in Japan ein grosser Star.)
(Sie ist eine sog. TV-Personality:
jemand, der in verschiedenen Rollen
im Fernsehen auftritt -
als Moderatorin von Spielshows,
als Talk-Gast,
als Kultur- und Politkommentatorin.)
(Laut, übertrieben)
Auf Wiedersehen!
(Lieblich) Sayonara.
(Haruka Christine
ist eine spannende Person.)
(Mit 16 ging sie von Zürich,
wo sie aufgewachsen war,
nach Japan, ins Heimatland
ihres Vaters. Allein, ohne Eltern.)
(Ich durfte sie kennenlernen,
was nicht selbstverständlich ist
bei ihrem Terminkalender.)
Die sind aber gar nicht scheu.
(Wir treffen uns
in einem Park in Tokio.)
(Ein ruhiges Gespräch mit ihr
zu führen, ist fast nicht möglich.)
(Die Leute
sind völlig aus dem Häuschen.)
(Haruka meint, das sei,
weil die Kirschblüten blühen.)
Warum
ist das Ausbrechen der Kirschblüten
in Japan etwas Besonderes?
Die Kirschblüte selbst
sieht man nur eine Woche lang.
Und das bedeutet Frühling in Japan.
Es ist genau die Zeit,
in der das Schuljahr aufhört
und wieder anfängt.
Und da sitzt man einfach
mit einer Decke auf die Wiese,
feiert und trinkt
bis in die Nacht hinein?
Ja, man hat Spass, isst z.B. Pizza.
* Christine spricht japanisch. *
Was hast du Lustiges gesagt?
Sie blühen noch nicht so stark.
Und was haben sie gesagt?
Sie sehen sehr viele Blüten,
vermutlich wegen des Alkohols.
Doppelt so viele.
(Ich bin überrascht.)
(Ich dachte immer,
die Japaner seien ein ruhiges,
kontrolliertes Volk, zurückhaltend.)
(Jetzt erlebe ich,
wie sie ausgelassen feiern ...
... und sogar am helllichten Tag
eins über den Durst trinken.)
(Wirklich zurückhaltend
sind sie auch nicht.)
Wo ist der Bahnhof? Dort hinten?
- Ja.
In der Nähe, dort drüben.
Oh, schau.
Der ist gar nicht schüchtern.
(Fotografieren
und fotografiert zu werden
scheint in Japan
kein grosses Thema zu sein.)
Wir gehen in einen Nudel-Shop,
Ramen-Shop.
Ramen.
- Ramen.
Okay, gern. Ich habe grossen Hunger.
- Das ist typisch japanisch.
Das ist der Automat,
hier muss man bestellen.
Wir geben jetzt die Bestellung ein?
- Ja.
Okay.
- Da kommen die Tickets raus.
1'000.
2'000.
Man zahlt im Voraus.
Dann wählt man, was man will.
Genau.
- Okay.
Das ist Ramen mit Nudeln Refill.
Das ist nur Ramen.
Es hat alles drauf,
aber wenn man noch mehr will,
kann man hier drücken.
Mir reicht das hier.
Einmal drücken?
- Genau.
Sehr praktisch.
- Gut. Bravo.
Das war's. Schon bezahlt und alles.
Einmal Dessert für mich,
einmal Ramen, und einmal Ei.
Ich wäre schon wieder aufgeschmissen.
Steht alles auf Japanisch.
Und jetzt?
Das sind die freien Plätze.
Hier können wir sitzen?
- Genau.
Mir gefällt's hier.
Das Spezielle an Ichiran ist:
Man kann sehr gut allein kommen.
Man sieht nicht,
wie die anderen essen.
Das ist gut.
Und das hier?
- Das ist ...
Water.
Sehr praktisch.
Das finde ich so genial an Japan,
man denkt immer an alles.
Das ist Ichiran.
Du hast die Nudeln zwar bestellt,
aber noch nicht gesagt,
wie du die Nudeln haben willst.
Das kann ich jetzt ausfüllen.
- Genau.
Dann hier drücken.
Speziell ist: Man sieht die Leute
nicht, und sie sehen uns nicht.
Sehr eigenartig.
Schüchterne Japaner
können allein hierherkommen.
(Und schon bringt
ein gesichtsloser Kellner die Suppe.)
Wie sagt man?
- Itadakimasu.
Itadakimasu.
(Kellner, die man nicht sieht, Gäste,
die sich abschotten - speziell.)
(Geht man sich in Japan
überhaupt aus dem Weg?)
(Stimmt es, dass man in Japan
keine Meinung haben darf?)
Viele haben ihre Meinung,
aber sie sagen sie trotzdem nicht.
Weil sie vielleicht Angst haben,
dass andere eine unterschiedliche
Meinung haben könnten
und sie dann nicht mehr gut
miteinander auskommen.
Dass der ganze Mensch irgendwie ...
... abgelehnt wird.
- Ja.
Also nicht nur die Meinung.
Die Stimmung ist sehr wichtig.
Wahrnehmen,
was um einen herum passiert ...
Die Stimmung lesen, ja.
(Ein lehrreiches Essen
mit Haruka Christine.)
(Wir gehen noch ein Haus weiter.)
Und jetzt?
Zum Schluss bringe ich dich noch
an einen typisch japanischen Ort.
Das Blaue dort?
- Das Blaue, ja.
Okay. Und das heisst?
Karaoke.
- Oh!
* Sanfter Gesang auf Japanisch *
Schön.
Vielen, vielen Dank.
- Vielen, vielen Dank.
* Pulsierende Musik *
(Am Abend will mir Dennis
das Tokioter Nachtleben zeigen.)
(Bevor er in Zürich
seinen Job als Digital Designer
bei einem Laufschuhproduzenten
antrat,
hatte er in Japan studiert
und in Tokio gearbeitet.)
(Er weiss,
wie man sich in der Stadt bewegt.)
Ist es hier eigentlich sicher?
Ich habe mein Portemonnaie
hier in der Tasche.
Ich trag meins hinten.
In Japan geht das, finde ich.
Sie sind sehr streng in Japan.
Strafen sind sehr drakonisch.
Du verlierst dein Gesicht.
Wenn du was anstellst,
wissen das alle.
(Weil die Japaner ein grosses
Zusammengehörigkeitsgefühl haben,
gibt es Dinge, die man
einfach nicht tut - stehlen z.B.)
(Die Angst vor dem Gesichtsverlust
hat also durchaus ihre Vorteile.)
Kabukichō.
- Kabukichō.
Das ist ein Rotlichtviertel
von Tokio.
Geht hier
die Tokioter Bevölkerung aus?
Oder nur, wenn man auf der Suche
nach dem Rotlicht ist?
Nein, es gibt auch gute Bars.
Man kann hier gut was trinken.
(Am Rand von Kabukichō liegt Golden
Gai, das alte Prostituiertenviertel.)
(Die Prostitution ist seit Ende
der 1950er-Jahre verboten.)
(Heute sind da,
wo früher die Bordelle waren, Bars.)
(Einige Hundert -
schön ineinander verschachtelt
und meist nicht grösser
als ein Wohnzimmer.)
Ist es okay?
Konichiwa.
* Gemütliche japanische Rap-Musik *
Grossartig, hier gefällt es mir.
- Es ist klein.
Schau, all die Drinks!
Stammgäste
haben ihre eigene Flasche.
Ah, jeder Gast
hat seine eigene Flasche?
Angeschrieben
mit dem Namen des Gastes.
Wenn ich hier Gast wäre,
hätte ich meine eigene Flasche
und würde jede Nacht hierherkommen?
Nicht jede Nacht. Vielleicht
einmal pro Woche, oder zweimal.
Kanpai.
- Kanpai.- Kanpai.
My name is Patrick.
Ich habe heute gelernt,
dass ich es so betonen muss:
Pa-torick.
Arbeitest du hier
oder gehört dir die Bar?
Nein, das hier ist nicht meine Bar.
Ich habe zwei Jobs.
Ich verkaufe Secondhandkleider
und arbeite hier.
Du verkaufst Kleider?
Die Kleider kaufe ich in den USA,
bringe sie hierher
und verkaufe sie online.
Du reist also viel?
Ja, ich besuche meine Verkäufer
jedes Jahr.
Das Leben in Tokio muss teuer sein.
Ja, sehr teuer.
In den USA
kostet dieses Shirt 1-2 $,
in Japan 5'000-6'000 Yen.
50 $.
- 50 Fr.?
Du kaufst sie für 2 $
und verkaufst sie für 5'000 Yen?
Das ist ein Geheimnis.
Du bist ein guter Verkäufer.
I love money.
(Yugo ist mir sympathisch.)
(Am liebsten würde ich ihn
bei ihm zu Hause fotografieren.)
(Dann sähe ich auch gleich,
wie jemand wie Yugo lebt.)
(Ich frage ihn, ob wir ihn zu Hause
besuchen dürften. Er sagt Ja.)
* Sanfte Musik *
(Dennis ist überrascht.)
(Dass man in Japan
jemanden zu sich nach Hause einlade,
sei eher ungewöhnlich.)
(Normalerweise finde das Sozialleben
ausserhalb
der eigenen vier Wände statt.)
Hier ist er.
Konichiwa. Guten Tag, wie geht es?
Gut. Schön, dich wieder zu sehen.
(Yugo ist 37. Seit ein paar Monaten
wohnt er wieder bei seinen Eltern.)
Das ist der Laden?
Grossartig!
Das ist, was du online verkaufst,
was du in deinem Webshop verkaufst?
Und alles ist aus zweiter Hand?
- Ja.
Ähm ... ja. 90 %.
Hier.
(Das Leben in Tokio ist sehr teuer.)
(Darum hat Yugo, wie viele Japaner,
zwei Jobs. Das ist anstrengend.)
(Aber noch viel anstrengender
war sein Leben als Büroangestellter,
als sog. Salaryman.)
Manchmal
konnte ich nachts nicht nach Hause.
Ich arbeitete in der Firma
und schlief in der Firma.
Wirklich?
- Yeah.
Du schliefst im Büro?
Wo, am Schreibtisch?
Am Schreibtisch.
Auf dem Schreibtisch. So:
Echt? Und am Morgen aufwachen
und weiter arbeiten?
Ja. Oft.
Wie lange hast du das gemacht?
- Vermutlich acht Jahre.
Acht Jahre!
- Ja, etwa acht Jahre.
(Jetzt hat er mehr Freizeit
und auch mehr Freiheit.)
(Aber es gibt Dinge, die als
Selbstständiger nicht möglich sind -
z.B. eine eigene Wohnung kaufen.)
(Ohne festes Einkommen
geht das in Japan nicht.)
(Dafür lebt er mit seinem Webshop
einen grossen Traum.)
Wow.
Wie findest du hier etwas?
Weisst du, was wo liegt?
Ja.
- Wo ist das Patagonia-Shirt?
Ich erinnere mich.
Du hast also ein System,
ohne ein System zu haben?
Ein System? Nein.
Kann ich dir helfen?
- Ja.
Ich kann einpacken.
Jetzt das Shirt?
Ich muss die Adresse schreiben.
Oh, kann ich probieren,
die Adresse zu schreiben?
Du? Auf Japanisch?
- Ich kann's versuchen.
Sind das chinesische oder
japanische Zeichen? Oder ein Mix?
Das sind Kanji. Japanische Zeichen,
aber ursprünglich aus China.
Chinese original.
- Okay.
Like this cross. Okay.
Sehr gut.
Es ist schwierig, echt.
- Nein, du machst das gut.
Ich glaube, der Name reicht, hier hat
es mir zu viele verschiedene Zeichen.
Kannst du die Adresse schreiben?
Ich?
- Ja.
Was wird dein Kunde denken?
Sehr gut. Besser als meins.
Ach, hör auf!
(Langsam ist unser Verhältnis so gut,
dass ich frage,
ob ich ein paar Fotos machen dürfe.)
Schau ernst!
(Meine Vermutung war richtig:
Yugo daheim ist ein gutes Sujet.)
Ein ganzes Leben in einem Bild.
(Und er ist ein guter Mensch.)
Ich wünsche dir viel Glück
mit deinem Shop und in der Bar.
Bye-bye.
(Yugo macht etwas,
das in der japanischen Gesellschaft
nicht viele wagen:
Er geht seinen eigenen Weg.)
(Ich bin froh, haben Dennis und ich
schon vorher beschlossen,
nach einer Woche Tokio
ein paar Tage aufs Land zu fahren.)
(Im Gewühl des Bahnhofs Shinagawa
suchen wir den Weg zum Shinkansen,
dem japanischen
Hochgeschwindigkeitszug,
der auf einem eigenen Schienennetz
bis zu 320 km/h schnell fährt.)
(Vor dem Einsteigen
machen wir es wie die Einheimischen:
Wir kaufen eine Bento-Box,
eine kleine Schachtel
mit lokalen Spezialitäten.)
(Take-away auf Japanisch.)
(Sehr gesund
und für 10 Fr. auch recht günstig.)
Du darfst nicht dort gehen.
(Der Shinkansen ist ein Wunderzug:
Genau da, wo es auf dem Bahnsteig
eingezeichnet ist,
ist die Tür zum Einsteigen.)
(Und pünktlich
fährt der Zug auch wieder los.)
(Präziser geht's fast nicht.)
In Japan isst du immer im Kreis.
Im Ernst?
Unten links oder oben rechts?
Ich würde beim Reis anfangen,
ich weiss nicht, was korrekt ist.
Es ist alles sehr fein,
mal süss, mal salzig, mal sauer.
Ich liebe es.
Darum musst du im Kreis essen,
um die Zunge wieder aufzufrischen.
Süss, salzig, sauer.
* Sanfte japanische Musik *
(Von Tokio sind wir mit dem Zug
nach Toyama im Westen gefahren.)
(Jetzt sind wir mit dem Auto
ins Bergdorf Ainokura unterwegs.)
(Übermüdet und im Linksverkehr.)
Kannst du mir aus meiner linken
Jackentasche ein Reisküchlein geben?
Ich habe einen Hungeranfall.
Das ist toll an den Snacks.
Hey,
du bist in die Dinger reingefahren!
Was?- In die orangen Pfosten
auf der linken Seite.
Das kann nicht sein.
- Der Spiegel ist verschoben.
Was?
- Du bist reingefahren.
Ich hab's gehört.
- Okay.
Was?
- Bumm, bumm hat's gemacht.
Auch das japanische Navi
ist gewöhnungsbedürftig.
Falls alles schiefgeht,
dort sind die Berge.
Und da müssen wir hin.
(Wir übernachten im privaten Haus
einer Gastfamilie. Einem Minshuku.)
(Inbegriffen sind die Übernachtung,
das Abendessen und das Frühstück.)
(Bed and Breakfast auf Japanisch.)
(Wie in allen traditionellen Häusern
in Japan
schläft man auf einem Futon
auf dem Boden,
der mit Tatami-Matten ausgelegt ist.)
(In meinem Zimmer versteckt sich
hinter drei Schranktüren
ein aufwendiger buddhistischer
Schrein, eine Art Hausaltar,
wie es ihn in den meisten
japanischen Häusern gibt.)
* Sie spricht japanisch. *
Sie sagt, das Zimmer
mit dem Hausaltar sei das schönste,
das man vergeben kann.
(Plötzlich steckt ein Mann
den Kopf durch die Tür.)
(Es ist Hiroshi Yamazaki,
Mayumis Mann.)
(Mir gefalle sein Haus, sage ich ihm,
und er erklärt mir
ein paar Eigenheiten.)
Der Rauch
stieg hoch und schwärzte das Holz.
Darum sind alle Würmer
und andere Schädlinge,
die das Holz kaputt machen würden,
weg.
Alles aus Holz, kein einziger Nagel.
* Sanfte japanische Klänge *
(Es ist kalt in Ainokura.)
(In japanischen Häusern
gibt es keine Heizungen,
nicht einmal in den Bergen.)
(Aber frieren müssen wir
in der Nacht trotzdem nicht.)
(Aus dem Feuer, in dem Mayumi
den Fisch fürs Abendessen brät,
nimmt sie ein Stück Kohle
und legt es in einen Tonbehälter.)
(Diese traditionelle
japanische Bettflasche
hält uns die ganze Nacht
wunderbar warm.)
* Sanfte japanische Musik *
(Am nächsten Morgen schneit es.)
(Eine gute Gelegenheit,
eine der heissen Quellen zu besuchen,
einen Onsen.)
(Hierhin
gehen viele Japanerinnen und Japaner
für ihr tägliches
Wasch- und Baderitual.)
Das ist der Vorraum.
Hier machst du dich bereit.
Alles ausziehen?
- Genau.
Das kleine Tuch kannst du mitnehmen.
Dort musst du dich von Kopf bis Fuss
waschen, bevor du ins Bad gehst.
Du hast ein Tattoo?
- Ja, warum?
In Japan ist es schwierig,
wenn du in ein Bad gehen willst.
Schwierig im Sinn von ...
Es wird assoziiert mit den Yakuza,
also der japanischen Mafia.
Haben das nur die Bösen?
Es ist verboten.
Aber du kannst es versuchen.
(Ich wage es.)
(Zum Glück sind an diesem Morgen
auch nicht viele Leute im Onsen.)
(Das Waschen vor dem Baden
ist wichtig.)
(Dabei wird nicht nur der Körper,
sondern auch der Geist gereinigt.)
(Erst wenn man ganz sauber ist,
geht man ins heisse Bad.)
(Ein schönes Ritual - und man kann
sich dabei wunderbar entspannen.)
* Sanfte japanische Musik *
(Wir sind bereit für die Fortsetzung
unseres Abenteuers.)
(Navi) In about 5 km turn left.
* Sanfte japanische Klänge *
(Ich startete meine Reise
vor einer Woche in Tokio.)
(In den letzten Tagen
war ich im kleinen Bergdorf Ainokura
im Westen des Landes.)
(Jetzt bin ich unterwegs
nach Onagawa im Nordosten.)
(Es gibt einen Grund,
warum ich genau in diese Stadt will.)
(2011 hat der Tsunami
Onagawa komplett zerstört.)
* Sanfte, bedrückende Klänge *
(Onagawa war
ein lebendiges Fischerstädtchen.)
(10'000 Menschen wohnten hier.)
* Unheimliche Klänge *
(Der Tsunami schluckte alles.)
(Das Meer, das den Menschen
so viel gibt, nahm ihnen alles.)
(827 Menschen
kamen hier in Onagawa ums Leben.)
(Die Stadt hat sich vom Tsunami
noch immer nicht erholt.)
Schau mal hier, Reste der Häuser.
- Oh, ja.
Wow.
(Viele Leute zogen weg
und kamen nie mehr zurück.)
(Heute leben in Onagawa
ein Drittel weniger Menschen
als vor dem Tsunami.)
(Früher war Onagawa
ein beliebtes Touristenziel.)
(Jetzt gibt es im Zentrum
keine Hotels mehr.)
(Mein Reisebegleiter
Dennis Ginsig und ich
müssen in einer Containersiedlung
übernachten.)
* Bedrückende Klänge *
(Am nächsten Morgen sehe ich,
wie weit fortgeschritten
der Wiederaufbau ist.)
(Mein erster Eindruck von gestern
täuscht:
Onagawa entsteht
nicht unten am Meer neu,
sondern v.a. rund ums alte Zentrum,
an den Hängen.)
(Teils schüttete man in den letzten
Jahren ganze Hügel neu auf,
damit die Wohnhäuser in Zukunft
vor dem Wasser sicher sind.)
(Auch das neue Zentrum
liegt höher als vor der Katastrophe -
8 m schüttete man hier auf.)
(Wohnhäuser gibt es hier keine mehr,
nur noch Läden und Restaurants.)
(Der Bürgermeister sagt,
das neue Zentrum
solle ein Begegnungsort werden.)
Sie beschlossen nach dem Tsunami,
Bürgermeister von Onagawa zu werden.
Ja, üblicherweise fängt man
in der japanischen Gesellschaft
erst mit 60 an, Verantwortung
für viele Dinge zu übernehmen.
Ich glaube, dass meine Generation
die Verantwortung
für die ersten Schritte
der Wiederauferstehung dieser Stadt
übernehmen soll.
In Japan gibt es viele Regeln,
die einschränken.
Wenn wir nach der Zerstörung hier
einen neuen Ort
frei gestalten könnten,
sähe ich das als grosse Chance.
Wenn ich richtig gehört habe,
gibt es aber auch neue Perspektiven.
Junge Leute
ziehen wieder in die Stadt.
Was können Sie dazu sagen?
Einheimische, die geblieben sind,
haben neue Geschäftsideen.
Und junge Leute
kommen nun von aussen hierher
und starten hier in Onagawa
ein neues Business,
wie z.B. der junge Herr
mit seinem Gitarrenshop dort drüben.
Ich zeige es Ihnen.
(Yoshiaki Suda bringt uns in
den Gitarrenladen vom Yosuke Kajiya.)
(Er kommt aus Tokio und
zog erst vor Kurzem nach Onagawa.)
Konichiwa.
* Sie sprechen japanisch. *
(Yosuke Kajiya stellt mit seinem Team
ganz spezielle Gitarren her:
Elektrogitarren für Rock-,
aber auch für traditionelle Musik.)
(Und die Teile werden geleimt,
nicht genagelt wie üblich.)
Was war für Sie der Grund,
hierher nach Onagawa zu kommen,
dieses Geschäft zu eröffnen
und hier Gitarren zu produzieren?
Als ich das erste Mal hierherkam,
spürte ich, dass dieser Ort
eine starke Energie ausstrahlt.
Die Leute versuchten bereits,
neue Geschäftsideen umzusetzen.
Die Fischfirmen z.B.
möchten neu nach Übersee verkaufen.
So dachte ich: "Diese Stadt
ist ein wunderbarer Ort,
um ein gutes Produkt herzustellen."
* Rockige Klänge *
(Bewundernd) Oh!
Dieser Riff ist ein Gitarrenintro
der Schweizer Band Gotthard.
Gotthard?
Er spielt Gotthard? Wow!
(Was für eine Überraschung!)
(Der Bürgermeister
ist auch ein Rocker.)
(Er ist Gitarrist
in einer Heavy-Metal-Band.)
* Er spricht japanisch. *
* Schnelle, rockige Klänge *
So geil!
Ich bin sehr beeindruckt,
Er ist ja ein richtiger Rocker.
* Dennis spricht japanisch. *
An Gotthard komme ich nicht heran.
Und woher kennen Sie Gotthard?
* Er spricht japanisch. *
Es sei eine Topband aus der Schweiz.
Sie sei auch nach Japan gekommen.
Das habe er gehört.
Sie waren als Fan am Konzert
und spielen sie auch selbst.
* Sie sprechen japanisch. *
Thank you, thank you very much.
* Rockige Gitarrenklänge *
(Sechs Jahre nach dem Tsunami
wohnen immer noch Menschen
in Containersiedlungen -
kalt, eng
und fast ohne Privatsphäre.)
(Und die neuen Siedlungen
im oberen Teil der Stadt
sind zwar schön und modern,
aber halt auch anonym.)
* Ruhige Klavierklänge *
(Eines der wenigen Gebäude
in Onagawa,
das nach dem Tsunami noch stand,
ist das Spital.)
(Es steht 16 m ü.M.)
(Als man es vor 20 Jahre baute,
achtete man darauf,
dass es hoch genug ist, damit es
bei einem Tsunami geschützt wäre.)
* Bedrückende Klänge *
(Ganz gereicht hat es allerdings
nicht, das Wasser stieg 18 m hoch.)
(Das ganze Erdgeschoss
wurde überflutet.)
(Die Daten des Spitals,
die Patientendossiers -
alles wurde damals zerstört.)
(So hoch stieg das Wasser damals.)
(Das Spital wurde nach dem Tsunami
mit Spendengeldern aus der Schweiz
wieder aufgebaut.)
(Neu wurde
in den obersten zwei Stockwerken
das Alters-
und Pflegeheim untergebracht.)
(Ich darf hier fotografieren,
will mir das aber durch einen
Einsatz als Hilfspfleger verdienen.)
Bitte ziehen Sie für Ihren Einsatz
die Angestelltenuniform an,
die wir hier täglich tragen.
Wir würden uns freuen,
wenn Sie uns heute helfen könnten.
Super, ich freue mich sehr darauf.
Vielen Dank.
* Er spricht japanisch. *
(Vor meinem Einsatz
in der Alterspflegeabteilung
stelle ich mich beim Chef des Spitals
vor, Dr. Mitsuru Saito.)
(Er war
während des Tsunamis im Spital.)
(Ich möchte von ihm wissen,
ob damals Menschen zu Schaden kamen.)
Ja, es wurden Menschen
aus dem Erdgeschoss weggespült.
Unsere Angestellten im ersten Stock
kamen knapp mit dem Leben davon.
Das Wasser drang ein, schwoll an
und schwemmte sie an die Decke hoch.
Sie hatten
nur noch knapp 30 cm Luft über sich,
dann liess das Wasser
glücklicherweise nach.
Sofort nach dem Tsunami
war es schwierig zu begreifen,
dass das, was sich
vor unseren Augen abspielte,
die Realität war
und nicht etwa ein Albtraum.
Ich glaube,
dass Sie in der oberen Abteilung
bereits ein Teil des Personals
kennengelernt haben.
Alle Angestellten, die an jenem Tag
im Spital gearbeitet haben,
wussten zuerst nicht,
was mit ihren Häusern
und ihren Familien geschehen war.
Trotz dieser bedrückenden
Ungewissheit
blieben sie pflichtbewusst im Spital
und kümmerten sich
unermüdlich um die Patienten.
(Weil nach dem Tsunami
viele wegzogen,
war kein so grosses Spital
mehr nötig.)
(Dafür gab es Platz
für ein Alterspflegeheim.)
Hallo miteinander.
Wie schon am Morgen angekündigt,
haben wir heute Besuch.
Konichiwa, konichiwa.
Dann schlage ich vor,
dass wir nun unsere Übungen machen.
Auch die Füsse bewegen!
(Man brauchte mehr Platz
fürs Altersheim:
In Onagawa gibt es, wie in ganz
Japan, immer mehr ältere Leute.)
Soll ich Ihnen helfen?
Mit dieser Hand nach hinten. So.
(Einerseits ist das schön,
andererseits ein Problem,
weil gleichzeitig
die Geburtenrate rapide sinkt.)
(Darum sind die Renten in Japan
nicht gesichert.)
(Dass die Menschen hier immer älter
werden, hat mehrere Gründe:
Sie leben und essen sehr gesund,
und das Gesundheitssystem
ist eines der besten der Welt.)
(Pflegerin) Tong, tong, tong, tong.
- (Alle) Tong, tong, tong, tong.
(Bis vor Kurzem lebten die Eltern
bis zum Tod bei ihren Kindern.)
(Das ist heute auch in Japan
immer seltener der Fall.)
(Und weil es
immer weniger Junge gibt,
gibt es auch immer weniger Pflege-
personal für die alten Menschen.)
(Dieses Problem
liesse sich wohl nur lösen,
wenn es mehr Zuwanderung
aus dem Ausland gäbe.)
(Doch da ist Japan streng,
die Hürden sind hoch,
auch für das Pflegepersonal.)
(Nicht einmal 2 % der Bevölkerung
in Japan sind Ausländer.)
* Sie sprechen japanisch. *
* Sie spricht japanisch. *
(Oberschwester Abe
macht sich Sorgen.)
(Wer soll sich in Zukunft
noch um die Alten kümmern?)
Spüren Sie, dass es immer mehr
alte Leute gibt in der Bevölkerung?
Ja, tendenziell leben die Jungen
nicht mehr bei den Eltern.
Alte Menschen
werden allein gelassen.
Oft wohnt eine alte Person
allein in einem Haus.
(Dazu kommt ein anderer
gesellschaftlicher Trend:
Immer mehr junge Menschen
gehen als Single durchs Leben.)
(Immer weniger Junge heiraten.)
Wäre es eine Lösung, dass jede
Familie wieder mehr Kinder hätte?
Ich glaube,
dass es mehr braucht als das.
Wenn die heute
verteilt lebenden Familien
wieder wie früher zueinander finden
und miteinander leben würden,
dann würde wohl eine bessere
Gesellschaft entstehen, denke ich.
Es ist wichtig, dass die Verbindung
wieder gestärkt wird
zwischen einzelnen Leuten und den
Familien, und auch lokal im Dorf.
Das ist der richtige Weg.
(Die Herausforderungen für Japan
sind gross.)
(Bis in 30 Jahren soll es einen
Drittel weniger Menschen geben.)
(Die meisten von ihnen
sind dann im Pensionsalter.)
(Ich weiss nicht, wie sich ein
Kollaps des Landes verhindern lässt.)
(Ich habe im Alterspflegeheim von
Onagawa viel gelernt und gesehen.)
(Masayo Abe ist 100 Jahre alt.
Sie hat in ihrem Leben viel gesehen.)
(Es waren intensive Tage im Norden.)
(Zwei Wochen
bin ich jetzt schon in Japan.)
(Dennis, mein Reisebegleiter, öffnete
mir in dieser Zeit viele Türen
und ermöglichte viele Begegnungen.)
(Und er erzählte mir viel
über die japanische Kultur.)
(Doch jetzt muss er zurück
in die Schweiz, zurück ins Büro.)
(Am Bahnhof Tokio
verabschieden wir uns.)
(Nun muss ich es alleine schaffen,
mit lokalen Übersetzerinnen.)
* Sanfte japanische Musik *
(Vor meiner Weiterreise ergatterte
ich am Bahnhof noch einen Job.)
(Ich darf einen Shinkansen, einen
Hochgeschwindigkeitszug, putzen.)
(Das klingt einfach,
ist es aber gar nicht,
wenn man weiss, wie hoch
die Ansprüche in Japan sind.)
(Ein Supervisor der Reinigungsfirma
gibt mir einen Crashkurs.)
(Das Wichtigste sei der Lappen:
Er müsse richtig gefaltet sein.)
(Und man müsse ihn richtig halten,
sonst gehe gar nichts.)
Ja, ja.
* Der Supervisor spricht japanisch. *
(Dann lerne ich, wie man einen Zug
und die Passagiere richtig empfängt.)
(Ja, das Reinigungspersonal
begrüsst den Zug und die Passagiere
mit einer Verneigung.)
(Dann geht es los: Die Passagiere
haben 3 Min. Zeit zum Aussteigen,
dann kommt das Kommando zum Putzen.)
(Wie von Geisterhand drehen sich
die Stühle in Fahrtrichtung.)
(Und auch der Rest
geschieht wie von Geisterhand.)
* Sie spricht japanisch. *
Arigato.
(7 Min. haben wir für einen Wagen.
Zum Glück sind wir zu zweit.)
Gut.
Die Kollegin
ist schon fünf Reihen weiter.
Jetzt verstehe ich das System mit
dem Lappen. Das ergibt schon Sinn.
(Wir haben es geschafft, bzw.
meine Kollegin hat es geschafft.)
(Sechs Monate lang
war sie in der Ausbildung,
bevor sie zum ersten Mal
allein einen Wagen putzen durfte.)
(Ich verstehe, warum.)
(Der Zug fährt pünktlich ab.)
(Pro Jahr hat ein Shinkansen
zusammengerechnet
nicht mehr als 1 Min. Verspätung.)
* Sanfte japanische Musik *
(Der Bahnhof von Kioto sieht ein
bisschen aus wie eine Raumstation.)
(Als er vor 20 Jahren eröffnet wurde,
diskutierte man ihn
in Japan sehr kontrovers.)
(Die einen empfanden ihn als Schand-
fleck für die historische Stadt,
die anderen waren begeistert
vom futuristischen Look.)
* Sanfte japanische Musik *
(Kioto ist eine sehr lebendige,
moderne Stadt.)
(Kioto hat aber -
als einzige grosse Stadt in Japan -
auch einen historischen Kern.)
(Der Grund dafür ist:
Kioto blieb im Zweiten Weltkrieg
als einzige grosse Stadt in Japan
von den Bombardements verschont.)
(Es ist Kirschblütenzeit. In Japan
die wichtigsten Wochen im Jahr.)
(Man feiert den Frühling,
den Anfang des Lebens.)
(In dieser Zeit in Kioto ein Hotel
zu finden, ist fast unmöglich.)
(Aber ich habe Glück.)
I would like
to check in for one night. Yes.
(Im Kapselhotel Nine Hours
gibt es noch freie ... ja, Kapseln.)
Okay. So.
Hier ist der Lift -
für Männer und Frauen getrennt.
Rot ist für Frauen?
(Seinen Namen Nine Hours -
9 Std. - trägt das Hotel,
weil man für eine Nacht in einer
Stadt nicht mehr braucht als 9 Std:
1 Std. für die Toilette, sieben
zum Schlafen, eine zum Aufstehen.)
(Alles ist reduziert
aufs Wesentliche:
Für das Gepäck ist wenig Platz,
dafür gibt's einen Pyjama
und Hausschuhe.)
(Wäre ich jünger,
würde ich möglichst oft
in einem solchen Hotel übernachten.)
(Jetzt bin ich froh,
dass es nur eine Nacht ist.)
* Futuristische Musik *
So stelle ich es mir im Weltall vor.
(Die Nacht ist kurz,
aber dafür habe ich gut geschlafen.)
(Ich bin froh, weil mein Tag
schon um 5.30 Uhr anfängt.)
(Zusammen mit meiner Übersetzerin
Toyo
mache ich mich auf ins Dojo
von Yoko Okamoto,
eine der wenigen
Kampfkunsttrainerinnen in Japan.)
(Yoko Okamoto ist 62,
sie ist ein Aikido-Sensei,
eine Aikido-Lehrerin,
und trägt den sechsten Dan,
den sechsten schwarzen Gurt.)
D.h., sie ist sehr erfahren,
und es ist auch ziemlich schnell
klar, wer hier der Meister ist.)
(Jetzt gebe es zuerst Zazen,
eine Sitzmeditation.)
Während des Zazen sitzt du so.
Die Augen sind nicht geschlossen.
Ja, so ist es gut.
* Heller Glockenschlag *
(Meine erste Lektion in Kampfkunst
ist zuerst die Kunst,
gegen mein Inneres zu kämpfen.)
* Heller Glockenschlag *
(40 Min. lang im Lotussitz,
mich nicht bewegen,
geradeaus schauen,
ein- und ausatmen,
Gedanken kommen
und wieder gehen lassen.)
(Eine spannende Erfahrung.)
* Heller Glockenschlag *
(Richtig zu atmen und zentriert
zu sein, ist im Aikido sehr wichtig.)
(Das ist ja schön, aber momentan
sind meine Beine verkrampft.)
(Ich muss mir meine Fotos
wieder verdienen.)
(Das ist gut, weil ich so eine
Beziehung zu den Menschen aufbaue
und Teil des ganzen Geschehens
werde.)
(Weil ich
noch nie Aikido ausgeübt habe
und in der Lektion v.a. im Weg wäre,
helfe ich zumindest beim Putzen.)
Ai ist die Harmonie,
Ki ist die Energie,
Do ist der Weg.
The path. The path.
- The path you have to go.
Aikido ist also ein Weg,
die Energie zu harmonisieren.
Harmonisieren mit der Natur und
jedem einzelnen Individuum und Ding,
das auf der Welt existiert.
(Yokos Schülerinnen und Schüler
kommen aus der ganzen Welt.)
(Sie bewegen sich
wie in einem Ballett.)
(Allen scheint jede Bewegung
klar zu sein.)
(Niemand spricht.)
Du arbeitest ohne Worte.
Folgen sie dir einfach?
Wie kann ich die Natur
und all die schönen Dinge erklären?
Sie sind einfach schön. Du musst sie
sehen und fühlen, wahrnehmen.
Das ist im Grunde dasselbe.
Für mich gibt es nichts zu erklären.
Ich werfe sie,
und sie müssen es fühlen.
* Mystische Klänge
mit wilden Trommelschlägen *
Der Weg des Aikido ist,
zu akzeptieren, ohne sich daran
zu klammern, ohne Widerstand.
Ergibt das Sinn?
- Noch nicht.
Wenn du aggressiv bist,
und ich werde auch aggressiv,
dann knallt es.
Wenn du wütend bist,
brauche ich aber
nicht wütend auf dich zu sein.
Ich akzeptiere es und lenke es um.
Wir sind zwei Personen.
Ich kann dich und mich
aber auch aus der Perspektive
einer dritten Person beobachten,
wie wenn ich uns
in einem Film sehen würde.
Wenn du also wütend wirst, brauche
ich das nicht persönlich zu nehmen.
Genau das geschieht auch
in der Sitzmeditation.
(Yoko sagt, Aikido müsse man erleben,
fühlen, nicht verstehen.)
(Eigentlich wie in der Fotografie.)
(Es heisst ja,
ein Bild sage mehr als 1'000 Worte.)
Würde Aikido mein Leben verändern?
Ich weiss nicht.
Was möchtest du denn verändern?
Vielleicht würde ich
ein bisschen ruhiger,
konzentrierter, geduldiger werden.
Genau darum geht es beim Aikido.
Great.
- Yes.
(Langsam verstehe ich:
Aikido ist also viel mehr als Sport.)
(Es ist
eine Persönlichkeitsschulung.)
(Man lernt, mit körperlichem Training
richtig auf Situationen
zu reagieren.)
(Mit Klarheit,
Respekt und eigener Stärke.)
(Ohne Aggression.)
(Genau so erlebe ich Yoko.
Eine faszinierende Frau.)
You don't have your glasses
but I think, they're good.
(Die letzte Etappe meiner Reise
beginnt kurz nach 4 Uhr morgens.)
(Ich bin in einem
buddhistischen Tempel in Kameoka,
in der Nähe von Kioto.)
* Sanfte japanische Musik *
(Ich lerne den Mönch Gensho Hozumi
kennen.)
(Er ist ein Roshi,
ein alter Zen-Meister.)
(Er führt
einen der wenigen Tempel in Japan,
in dem auch Ausländer
Zen lernen können.)
Ich mache einen Kreis um den Stein.
Du machst den äusseren
in Verbindung dazu.
Darum: Alle Menschen sind verbunden.
Zen öffnet das Herz.
Nichts ist für die Ewigkeit.
Ich kann ein neues Muster machen,
wenn ich will.
Jede Tätigkeit ist in sich perfekt,
wenn man die ganze Energie
auf den Augenblick lenkt.
Das Wichtigste ist das Selbst.
Man wendet sich dem Inneren
desSelbst zu, dem wahren Selbst.
Mit dieser spirituellen, gesunden
Haltung bringt man den Körper,
die Atmung und den Geist in Ordnung.
Geist und Körper genesen.
Diese drei Punkte zu trainieren -
das macht das Leben mit Zen aus.
* Gong *
(Es ist Zeit für das Frühstück.)
Nehmt die Stäbchen aus der Hülle
und platziert sie rechts.
Dann öffnet die Servietten,
nehmt die Schüsselchen
mit der linken Hand, von links her!
(Francisco,
ein Schüler von Roshi Gensho,
erklärt uns westlichen Besuchern
die Regeln.)
(Im Zen soll nichts
die Gedanken ablenken.)
(Darum ist sogar beim Essen
alles streng ritualisiert.)
Jetzt die nächste Schüssel.
* Japanisch *
Bitte esst schnell und still.
* Er spricht japanisch. *
Bitte nicht den Rettich essen.
Legt die Stäbchen nicht hin,
egal was passiert.
Esst den Rettich.
Reinigt die Stäbchen.
Legt sie zurück in die Hülle.
Trinkt das Wasser.
Das ist die Zen-Weise, zu speisen.
Alles wird genau
und bewusst gemacht.
Das ist etwas vom Wichtigsten.
* Er spricht japanisch. *
* Sanfte japanische Klänge *
(Wir wechseln in einen
anderen Tempel von Roshi Gensho.)
(Hier machen wir
eine Sitzmeditation.)
(Langsam atmen wir ein ...
und wieder aus.)
(Das soll helfen, sich auf das Hier
und Jetzt zu konzentrieren.)
(Doch so einfach ist das gar nicht.)
* Schläge *
(Ich frage mich, was Roshi da macht,
und befürchte, dass es mich
als Nächsten treffen könnte.)
(Tatsächlich.)
(Ich überstehe es und bin nach
dem langen Sitzen recht entspannt.)
(Das sei auch der Sinn der Schläge,
sagt der Roshi.)
Im Zazen sammelt sich die Kraft beim
Tanden, dem Zentrum des Körpers.
Hier kommt die Kraft her.
Dein Zentrum ist schlaff.
Dein Tanden sollst du stärken,
damit deine Willenskraft
und Energie fliessen können.
* Kraftspruch *
Der alte Mann hat Kraft.
Alles von hier?
Zen-Power
ist das spirituelle Bewusstsein,
mit allem verbunden zu sein.
Ich zeige dir die innere Kraft
mit meinem Körper,
so ist dieses Ki
leichter zu verstehen.
(Und dann sagt der Roshi, dass ich
ihm auf den Bauch sitzen soll.)
Wie schwer bist du?
Bald 90 kg wahrscheinlich, 88 kg.
Aufstehen?
(Dann demonstriert mir Roshi,
was es heisst, wenn man sein Ki,
seine ganze Energie,
im Zentrum des Körpers hat.)
Wenn man richtig atmet
und geistig wach ist,
wird man sich seiner prächtigen
Seele bewusst und entwickelt sich.
Heute nennt man das auch
Mindfulness, Achtsamkeit.
Das Wichtigste beim Zen ist,
sein Zentrum zu finden.
(Meine Fotos habe ich mir
wieder mal verdient.)
(Und ich habe nun eine Idee,
was Zen bedeutet.)
* Sanfte japanische Musik *
(Von Kioto geht meine Reise
weiter nach Osaka.)
(Die Stadt
ist ein altes Handelszentrum
und heute eines der wichtigsten
Industriezentren Japans.)
(Osakas Hafen
ist einer der wichtigsten im Land.)
(Osaka gefällt mir
ab der ersten Sekunde.)
(Die Stadt ist lebendig,
weniger hektisch als Tokio.)
(Die Menschen
sind entspannt und recht witzig.)
(Am Fluss treten Idols auf - junge
Menschen, die berühmt werden wollen.)
(Die Frauen stehen auf der einen, die
Männer auf der anderen Flussseite.)
(Das ist recht symbolisch für Japan.)
(Ich habe gelesen, Japanerinnen und
Japaner binden sich immer weniger.)
(Immer mehr leben allein, hätten
Angst, eine Beziehung einzugehen.)
(Warum das so ist,
will ich in der Singles Bar Eden
herausfinden.)
(Frauen, die einen Mann suchen,
warten in einem separaten Raum.)
(Wenn der Barmanager das Gefühl hat,
es gäbe einen Mann,
der zu einer der Frauen passt,
bringt er sie zu ihm.)
(Ich frage
den Manager Shingo Hashiguchi,
ob er mich zu einer
Single-Frau bringen könnte,
natürlich ohne Paarungsabsicht.)
(Ich würde sie gerne fotografieren
und mit ihr reden.)
Konichiwa!
Can I sit down?
(Ich darf zu Yuki.)
(Sie ist 31 und seit etwas mehr
als einem Jahr Single.)
Ist es schwierig,
hier einen Mann zu finden?
Es ist schwierig, den ersten
Eindruck richtig einzuschätzen.
Okay. Träumen Sie von einer Familie?
Ja, natürlich.
Mit vielen Kindern?
Zwei wären perfekt.
Sind Sie nervös
an einem solchen Abend?
Ja, ich bin aufgeregt.
(Shingo kommt zurück.)
(Für zwei Frauen am Nebentisch hat er
zwei passende Männer gefunden.)
(25 Min. lässt er sie
beieinander sitzen.)
(Spätestens dann sollte man wissen,
ob man sich wieder treffen will
oder nicht.)
(Weiss man es bis dann nicht, wird es
nichts, ist die Haltung hier.)
(Der erste Eindruck
ist also entscheidend.)
(Ist die Zeit um, tauscht man
entweder Telefonnummern aus
oder man geht zurück zum Manager.)
(Dieser gibt einem ein Feedback zum
Treffen - wie eine Art Liebescoach.)
(Ich setze mich in der Zwischenzeit
zu diesen drei Männern
im Abteil nebenan.)
Seid ihr auf der Suche nach Liebe?
Ja.
Jemanden zum Heiraten?
Ja, heiraten.
Du willst heiraten?
- Ja.
Seid ihr möglicherweise schüchtern?
Ja, wir sind Japaner.
(Yuki sitzt immer noch
allein am Tisch.)
(Wenn Manager Shingo nicht das Gefühl
hat, es könnte sich etwas ergeben,
bringt er seine Gäste nicht mit
anderen zusammen. Yuki gibt auf.)
(Dieses Wochenende wird sie
wohl wieder allein verbringen.)
Warum haben Sie heute Abend
keinen Mann gefunden für Yuki?
Warum wohl?
Heutzutage ist es schwieriger,
jemanden am Arbeitsplatz
kennenzulernen.
Wegen der vielen Überstunden
hat man kaum Zeit, Leute zu treffen.
Solche Orte wie hier gehören
zu den wenigen Gelegenheiten.
Yuki ist gekommen,
weil sie von Freunden gehört hat,
die hier früher einmal
ihren Partner gefunden haben.
(Sie ist auch wieder
zurück am Platz.)
(Der Mann, den sie getroffen hat,
habe zwar eine gute Ausstrahlung,
aber irgendwie
habe es nicht gepasst.)
(Ihr sei Konversation sehr wichtig,
und in diesem Gespräch habe es
zu viele Pausen gegeben.)
(Das erzählt sie Manager Shingo,
der jetzt als Coach bei ihr ist.)
Was haben Sie
von Manager Shingo gelernt?
Anstatt auf das Äussere zu schauen,
sollte ich auf meine Gefühle
für diese Person achten.
Gefühle sind wichtiger
als das Aussehen.
Shingo, welchen Rat würden Sie
japanischen Männern geben
und welchen japanischen Frauen?
Männer tauschen zwar
die Kontaktinformationen aus,
aber sie sind so tollpatschig in
der darauffolgenden Kommunikation.
* Er spricht japanisch. *
Frauen urteilen viel zu schnell.
Frauen müssten sich
nach diesem Treffen
mindestens noch
zu einem Dinner verabreden.
Und so den Mann noch
ein bisschen besser kennenlernen.
(Bis vor Kurzem gab es in Japan
v.a. arrangierte Hochzeiten.)
(Liebeshochzeiten waren selten.
Heute ist das anders.)
(Mit der Freiheit sind auch die
Ansprüche gestiegen, scheint mir.)
(Und vielleicht
auch die Überforderung.)
* Pulsierende Musik *
(Einen grossen Modernisierungsschub
hat Japan in den 1970er-
bis 1990er-Jahren gemacht.)
(In diesen Jahren ist auch
die Wirtschaft explodiert.)
(Trotz den Veränderungen behielt
die Tradition ihren Stellenwert.)
(Tradition und Moderne gehen
erstaunlich gut zusammen in Japan.)
(In einem ruhigen Viertel von Osaka
treffe ich Yasuo Miichi.)
(Er beherrscht
ein jahrhundertealtes Handwerk.)
Konichiwa.
* Sie sprechen japanisch. *
(Yasuo Miichi schnitzt Masken
für das Noh-Theater.)
(Das ist eine 700 Jahre
alte Theaterform,
die sich bis heute
kaum verändert hat.)
(Alle Rollen
werden von Männern gespielt.)
(Welche Figur es ist,
erkennt man an den Masken.)
(Sie sind das zentrale Element
im Noh-Theater.)
(Je nachdem,
wie der Schauspieler den Kopf hält,
verändert sich
der Gesichtsausdruck der Masken.)
Kumoraseru bedeutet,
der Maske einen traurigen Ausdruck
zu verleihen.
Und wenn man sie
so nach oben richtet,
dann bekommt sie
einen helleren Ausdruck.
Ein Beispiel:
Hier habe ich ein Gesicht
auf das gefaltete Papier gezeichnet.
So etwas Ähnliches
macht man auch mit der Noh-Maske.
(Ich möchte Yasuo Miichi
fotografieren,
am liebsten mit natürlichem Licht,
damit die schöne Stimmung
in seinem Atelier
auf den Bildern zu sehen ist.)
(Der Mann beeindruckt mich.)
(15 Jahre lang ging er in die Lehre,
um sein Handwerk zu lernen.)
(Erst nach zehn Jahren
durfte er zum ersten Mal
selber eine Maske schnitzen.)
(Auch nach 40 Jahren macht er die Ar-
beit immer noch mit grosser Hingabe.)
Ich habe in den letzten Wochen
auf unserer Reise gelernt,
dass man in Japan
sein wahres Gesicht nicht zeigt.
Wie stark denken Sie, Herr Miichi,
dass diese Noh-Kunst auch etwas
sehr typisch Japanisches ist,
sein wahres Gesicht zu verbergen?
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob man so
direkt einen Bezug herstellen kann,
zwischen Noh
und dieser japanischen Gewohnheit.
Es gab einen historisch wichtigen
Noh-Spieler, dessen Lehre lautete:
Man soll etwas nicht aktiv -
explizit - darstellen,
sondern implizit spüren lassen.
Z.B. gibt es beim Auftreten
auf der Bühne eine Haltung,
bei der die Maske
einen bestimmten Winkel hat.
Wenn man diesen Winkel
auch nur ganz sanft verändert,
wird etwas ausgedrückt.
Die Darstellungsweise
ist also sehr eingeschränkt.
(So gesehen passt Noh halt doch
zu Japan, wo man vieles nicht sagt.)
(Man muss spüren, fühlen,
damit man versteht.)
Wunderschön!
Würden Sie für mich eine
fertige Maske vors Gesicht halten?
(100 Std. arbeitet Yasuo Miichi
an einer Maske.)
(Das Wichtigste sei,
dass jede Maske eine perfekte Kopie
ihrer Vorgängerinnen sei.)
(Künstlerische Freiheit,
eine Neuinterpretation
verträgt es nicht in der Noh-Kunst.)
(Natürlich würde ich die Masken
auch gerne im Einsatz sehen.)
(Yasuo Miichi vermittelt mir
einen Besuch im Kongo-Noh-Theater.)
(Hiroshi Kongo führt das Theater
in 26. Generation.)
(Seine Vorfahren
gründeten es vor über 650 Jahren.)
Ich kann nicht viel sehen.
Ich muss die Maske gut polstern,
weil ich sie stundenlang trage.
(Die Maske ist über 300 Jahre alt.)
(Hiroshi Kongo
behandelt sie wie einen Schatz.)
(Sein Sohn Tatsunori, der das Theater
bald in 27. Generation führt,
verwandelt sich jetzt gerade
in eine Frau.)
(Es ist nur für eine Probe,
aber trotzdem sehr aufwendig.)
(Die Tradition sagt, in dem Moment,
in dem der Noh-Spieler
die Maske aufsetze,
fahre der Geist der Figur in ihn.)
* Sanfte, tiefe Klänge *
(Das Noh-Theater
ist streng formalisiert.)
(Jede Bewegung ist genau festgelegt -
seit Jahrhunderten.)
Sie verstecken Ihr Gesicht
hinter einer Maske,
müssen Ihr Gesicht verstecken.
Fehlt da für einen Schauspieler
nicht etwas ganz Wichtiges?
Es gibt auch Rollen, bei denen
keine Maske getragen wird.
Aber auch dort muss die Mimik
des Schauspielers neutral bleiben.
Das wird Untermaske genannt.
Das eigene Gesicht wird dann
gewissermassen als Maske getragen.
Gefühle werden also nie
über die Mimik ausgedrückt.
Es ist eher etwas, das aus
dem tiefen Inneren herauskommt.
(Eine sehr spezielle Theaterform, die
ich irgendwie nicht ganz verstehe,
aber ich bin beeindruckt
von der Eleganz.)
(Von Osaka fliege ich nach Okinawa,
der Hauptinsel einer ganzen Gruppe
von kleineren Inseln,
ca. 1'200 km weiter im Süden.)
(Das Klima in Okinawa ist tropisch.)
(Ich habe mich bei WWOOF angemeldet,
den Willing Workers on Organic Farms,
den freiwilligen Helfern
auf Biohöfen.)
(D.h., ich gehe arbeiten
und darf bei den Bauern wohnen.)
(Die Begrüssung bei meiner
Gastfamilie ist ... stürmisch.)
(Aber ausser dem Hund
scheint niemand hier zu sein.)
Oh, ich habe
den richtigen Ort gefunden.
Konichiwa!
Ich freue mich, Sie kennenzulernen.
Ich bin Manabu.
Akiko!
- Nice to meet you.
Such a beautiful place!
(Auf den ersten Blick
gefällt es mir im Dschungel.)
(Akiko ist vor 13 Jahren
nach Okinawa gezogen.)
(Ihr gefalle es hier besser
als auf Festlandjapan,
die Menschen seien offener
und entspannter.)
Sie haben ein Zimmer für Gäste?
Normalerweise haben wir jeweils
eine WWOOFer-Person.
So, dieses Unkraut
musst du schneiden.
Okay.
Gibt es gefährliche Tiere hier?
Schlangen. Ja.
Deshalb machst du am besten so,
bevor du anfängst.
Danke dir.
- Danke.
Arigato.
Los geht's!
(Mit einer kleinen rostigen Sichel
Unkraut schneiden
in der feuchtwarmen,
tropischen Hitze:
Ich bezahle einen hohen Preis
für mein Abendessen.)
(Meine Gastfamilie
ist keine richtige Bauernfamilie.)
(Akiko ist Juristin, arbeitet
aber nicht mehr auf dem Beruf.)
(Und Manabu ist Keramikkünstler.)
(Er kam v.a. wegen des guten Lehms
nach Okinawa.)
* Sanfte japanische Klänge *
(Der Boden ist nicht nur
wegen des Lehms sehr gut,
er ist auch sehr fruchtbar,
das Unkraut wuchert wie verrückt.)
(Yamagamis sind, wie viele Menschen
auf Okinawa, Selbstversorger.)
(Zum Abschluss meiner Gartenarbeit
steche ich noch die Frühlingszwiebeln
für das Abendessen.)
(Akiko und Manabu haben vier Kinder,
zwei sind noch zu Hause.)
Das ist das Okinawa-Küchengerät
Shirishiri.
Wie heisst das?
- Shirishiri.
Klingt wie eine Reibe.
Ah, so wie das Geräusch.
- (Beide) Shirishirishiri.
Shirishiri ...
(Ich gebe mir richtig Mühe,
das Shirishiri richtig zu benutzen.)
Geht's?
Ja, bis jetzt
noch ohne Blutvergiessen.
Du kannst aufhören.
Kann ich den Rest essen?
- Ja, ja.
(Alle) Kanpai.
Thank you very much for ...
... welcoming me.
- You're welcome.
And here we have fish.
(Ich liebe das japanische Essen.)
(Es ist leicht und alles ist frisch.)
(Und mit einem guten Sake dazu,
dem japanischen Reiswein,
gibt es auch gute Gespräche.)
(Akiko erzählt von der schwierigen
Geschichte von Okinawa.)
(Sie sagt, die Menschen hier
fühlten sich als Opfer.)
Früher war es
ein eigenständiges Königreich,
dann wurde es von Japan annektiert.
Und die Menschen
verloren ihre Identität?
Ja, Japan gegen Okinawa.
Japan hat Okinawa
immer diskriminiert.
Und Okinawa war im Zweiten Weltkrieg
der einzige Ort,
wo an Land gekämpft wurde.
Die Amerikaner haben nicht
auf der Hauptinsel gekämpft.
Sie gingen nicht nach Tokio,
sie haben es nur bombardiert.
Die Amerikaner haben dann
für ihre Militärbasen
den Einheimischen Land weggenommen
und sind geblieben.
Wegen der Geschichte
fühlen sich die Menschen auf Okinawa
doppelt als Opfer.
Betrogen und benutzt, so fühlt sich
v.a. die ältere Generation.
Darum protestiert
die ältere Generation
gegen die US-Präsenz,
aber es ändert sich nichts.
(Es hat mit Unkraut jäten angefangen
und am Ende wurde der Tag
sogar noch politisch. Spannend.)
* Sanfte japanische Musik *
(Das mit dem Protest
lässt mir keine Ruhe.)
(In der Nähe sollen Demonstranten
den Bau einer US-Basis blockieren.)
(Hinako, meine Übersetzerin,
weiss mehr.)
Heute Morgen ist die Polizei
bereits vor Ort.
In einer halben Stunde wird sie
beginnen, den Platz zu räumen.
(Unvorstellbar:
Auseinandersetzungen mit der Polizei
im friedlichen Japan.)
(Eine Demo in einem Land,
in dem man nicht einmal
seine Meinung sagt.)
(Das ist doch
recht aussergewöhnlich.)
* Japanischer Sprechgesang *
(Die Sicherheitsleute der
Militärbasis sind zurückhaltend.)
(Sie kennen die Demonstranten.)
(Einige von ihnen machten das
seit 20 Jahren, sagt mir einer.)
(Dann kommen zwei Polizisten.
Sie wollen wissen, was wir machen.)
(Sie stellen sich mit Visitenkarte
vor, bedanken sich für die Auskunft
und verabschieden sich freundlich.)
(Doch dann fährt die Polizei
gröberes Geschütz auf.)
(So geht das jeden Tag.)
(Die Polizei löst die Demo auf,
damit die Lastwagen
auf die Baustelle können.)
(Jede Minute, in der nicht weiter-
gebaut werden kann, kostet Geld -
genau das wollen die Demonstranten.)
(Sie wollen die Amerikaner weg haben
von ihrer Insel,
weil immer wieder Soldaten
Frauen belästigen,
weil sie die Natur kaputt machen,
aber auch,
weil die Menschen auf Okinawa fürch-
ten, Ziel von Angriffen zu werden.)
(Nordkorea ist nicht weit entfernt.)
(Die Menschen auf dieser Insel
haben schon sehr viel durchgemacht,
wovon v.a. die sehr alten Menschen
auf Okinawa berichten können.)
(Und von ihnen gibt es einige.)
(In Okinawa gibt es nämlich
das Dorf der Hundertjährigen.)
(Es heisst Ogimi. Hier sollen die
ältesten Menschen der Welt leben.)
(Ich habe mit Hana Miyagi abgemacht.)
(Sie ist 93
und Mutter von zehn Kindern.)
(Sie hat den Zweiten Weltkrieg
miterlebt,
als die Amerikaner
Okinawa erobert haben.)
Was halten Sie von den Entwicklungen
der letzten Jahrzehnte in Japan
und auf Okinawa?
Unter der Kontrolle der japanischen
Regierung waren wir immer arm.
Seit die Amerikaner hier sind,
sind wir reicher.
Sie sind also froh,
dass die Amerikaner hier sind?
Ja, ich bin dankbar und glücklich,
dass sie uns beschützen.
Reden wir über Ihren Alltag.
Wie sieht er aus?
Jeden Tag züchte ich u.a. Goya.
Das typische gesunde Gemüse hier.
Ich pflanze Goya an,
entferne die Insekten und Schnecken
aus meinem Garten.
Das ist
mein morgendliches Fitnesstraining.
* Sie spricht japanisch. *
Das ist eine Goya.
DasGeheimnis Ihres hohen Alters.
Wie denken Sie über die jungen Leute?
Heutzutage
gehen alle gleich ins Spital,
wenn sie ein wenig Fieber haben.
Meine zehn Kinder
waren nie im Spital,
wir hatten kein Geld für so was.
Ich machte ihnen ein Getränk
mit Wildkräutern und Zucker.
Das senkt das Fieber.
Das Fieber geht auch weg, wenn man
Bananenblätter aufs Genick legt,
wie ein Kissen.
So machten wir das.
(Das Leben auf Okinawa ändert sich
wie überall in Japan.)
(Nicht nur wegen des Einflusses
aus dem Westen, aber auch.)
(Traditionen gehen verloren.)
Alles im Garten ist Gemüse.
Das kannst du essen.
Arigato.
Mmh, good!
Ich esse das immer.
She wants to collect it? Aha, okay.
* Fröhliches Lachen *
(Dassdie Leute in Ogimi so alt
werden, hat verschiedene Gründe.)
(Das gesunde Essen ist einer,
aber auch das Klima
und die gute soziale Vernetzung im
Dorf haben einen grossen Einfluss.)
(Einmal in der Woche treffen sich
die ältesten Frauen der Welt
im Gemeindezentrum von Ogimi.)
(Hier können Hana Miyagi
und ihre Kolleginnen
auch ihre Gesundheit checken lassen.)
(Dass die Frauen in Ogimi
auch gesund alt werden,
könnte damit zusammenhängen,
dass man hier auf der Insel nach
dem Grundsatz hara hachibu lebt.)
(Hara hachibu heisst:
Füll deinen Bauch nur zu 80 %.)
(Mehr sei ungesund.)
Sprichst du Japanisch,
verstehst du Japanisch?
Als ich jung war,
war ich sehr hübsch
und meine Haut war wunderschön.
So alt bin ich jetzt.
Ich bin jetzt 90.
Du schwitzt. Komm, ich trockne dich
etwas mit dem Taschentuch ab.
You're so nice.
Du hast schöne Arme.
Was arbeitest du?
Ich bin Fotograf -
Shashin-karesh.
(Gut, dass mich Aiko Miyagi
an meine Arbeit erinnert.)
(Ich hätte sie vor lauter
Zärtlichkeiten fast vergessen.)
* Sanfte japanische Musik *
(Was für eine Zeit in Okinawa.
Der Abschied fällt mir nicht leicht.)
(Ich gehe noch weiter Richtung Süden,
noch einmal 430 km,
und zwar auf die Insel Ishigaki,
die ganz in der Nähe
von Taiwan liegt.)
* Sanfte japanische Musik *
(Am nächsten Morgen
besuche ich Tomohiro.)
(Dieser Mann soll eine
ganz besondere Geschichte haben.)
Nice to meet you.- Thank you
very much for welcoming us.
What a wonderful place to live.
(Tomohiro baut Sabani.)
(Das sind traditionelle Boote,
die ganz aus Holz gemacht sind.)
Und da gibt es
keine Metallschrauben oder Nägel?
Wenn du Metallnägel verwendest,
werden die
nach zehn bis 20 Jahren rostig
und es bildet sich ein Loch
rundherum.
Der Nagel wird lose und fällt raus.
Ein Bambusstift hingegen
wird eins mit dem Holz des Bootes.
Solange das ganze Holz hält,
kannst du das Boot benutzen.
Wenn ein Stück bricht,
kann ich es heraussägen
und ein neues Stück einfügen.
(Tomohiro
kommt ursprünglich aus Tokio,
wo er in verschiedenen Berufen
gearbeitet hat.)
(Aber richtig zufrieden war er nie.)
(Es wurde ihm alles zu viel
und er beschloss,
mit seiner Familie
nach Ishigaki auszuwandern.)
(In Ishigaki lernte Tomohiro
einen alten Bootsbauer kennen.)
(Er war 82 und wollte sich
langsam zurückziehen.)
(Tomohiro war von der traditionellen
Handwerkskunst sofort fasziniert.)
(Der alte Bootsmacher zeigte ihm,
wie er selber Sabani bauen kann.)
(Endlich fand Tomohiro
seine Bestimmung.)
(Am Sunset Beach liegt Tomohiros
eigenes Sabani vor Anker.)
More?
- Okay.
(Normalerweise fährt er
mit Touristengruppen aufs Meer.)
(Heute will er mit mir schnorcheln.)
Hat sich dein Leben verändert,
seit du hier lebst?
Während ich in Tokio arbeitete,
um meine Familie zu ernähren,
versteifte sich
meine innere Haltung:
Ich merkte,
ich arbeite, um zu überleben.
Ohne Arbeit kein Leben.
Ohne Geld kein Leben.
Hier auf Ishigaki änderte sich
meine Mentalität langsam.
Es funktioniert auch anders
und einfacher:
Von der Natur rundherum
erhält man Wasser
und man kann Nahrung anbauen,
damit man essen und überleben kann.
Die Dinge sind da,
und du kannst anfangen zu leben
und hast Zeit für die Familie.
Was muss ich wissen,
bevor ich ins Wasser springe?
Mach Druckausgleich,
wenn du abtauchst.
Kannst du das?
Okay.
Beautiful!
(Ich verstehe, was Tomohiro meint,
wenn er sagt,
er habe hier mit seiner Frau Akemi
und den beiden Kindern
das Paradies gefunden.)
(Der Sohn ist schon älter. Tochter
Urara lebt noch bei den Eltern.)
Urara ist hier auf Ishigaki geboren.
Es gibt kaum Einschränkungen.
Wir können unsere Familienzeit
selber gestalten.
Nachbarn sind wie eine erweiterte
Familie. Wir sind glücklich.
* Sanfte japanische Musik *
Wenn ich das richtig sehe,
hast du zwar weniger,
aber dein Leben
ist viel besser als früher.
* Er spricht japanisch. *
Das stimmt.
Ich finde, Glück hängt nicht
vom Anhäufen von vielen Dingen ab.
Mein neuer Fokus:
Wie mache ich mein Leben reicher?
Wie kann ich eine tiefere Erfüllung
finden mit dem, was ich habe?
Das macht mich viel glücklicher.
(Ich bin
vor bald sechs Wochen losgezogen,
um mit meiner Fotokamera
Japan zu entdecken.)
(Auf eine Art,
wie man es sonst nicht kennt.)
(Mein Ziel: ein Buch über dieses Land
und seine Gegensätze zu machen.)
(Ich bin so vielen
verschiedenen Menschen begegnet,
wie ich es nie erwartet hätte.)
(Sie gaben mir einen Einblick
in ihr Leben.)
(Japan wird mir wohl
trotzdem immer fremd bleiben,
aber ich verstehe es nach
dieser Reise ein bisschen besser.)
(Und ich weiss:
Ich will zurückkommen.)
(Tief in mir drin hat dieses Land,
haben diese Menschen
etwas in mir berührt.)
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Sabine Näpflin - 2020